I'm gonna put the chocolates right here
okay okay you can only have three of
them I'm gonna give you three of them
but wait you have to wait till mommy
comes back okay I have to go to the
bathroom so let me go to the bathroom
and then you can have it okay oh you're
gonna wait for mommy okay wait from the
end in the cup three okay Kylie Jenner
put two year old daughter stormy to the
ultimate test and she passed with flying
colors
[Music]
even when stormy almost went for those
M&Ms she stopped herself and started
singing about patient
so yeah Kylie was super impressed with
her little ones behavior stormy wet stir
master of Community Challenge yeah she's
I mean it's so much fun
Kylie captioned her video quote OMG my
baby I had to take part in this
challenge and even big says Kim
Kardashian was impressed commenting oMG
how perfect this would not be the case
with chai or especially Saint Kylie has
been giving us all sorts of glimpses at
her and Stormies life in quarantine
I have bought her every single outdoor
toy could imagine she has bouncy houses
out there water toys she's been a fool
every day I'm just ready to make bitter
little slip in blood I gotta slip inside
it's not here you know I got everything
I'm just trying to make she's been
outside every day just living her best
life I'm trying to repair what I take
with her entertained a baby and like
realize what that there's no idea what's
going on know everything and in March a
source told ET Kylie and Travis for
co-parenting with ease and had gotten
back together quote at the end of the
day the couple is happy to have their
family back together
she takes more after you or Travis um
she is the perfect mixture of both of us
[Music]